[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of diverse topics on kind of data
science from high-end applications to
kind of a more low-level nitty-gritty
stuff estimating uncertainties on your
machine learning prediction interpret
about machine learning in the healthcare
space smoking on is called cream kind of
infection
[Music]
none focus is an organization that
serves kind of two missions one is to
directly support open source computer
programming tools we physically sponsor
them we support them in many different
ways and the part two of our mission is
to support the community of those users
and developers as well and one of the
biggest ways we can do that is to apply
data because pi data is a global program
of them focus that brings together the
community yeah we have about 40 speakers
it's pretty talks for tutorials to
keynotes the workshop is an in-depth
tutorial with interactive about
different subjects so yesterday we had
recommender systems but we also had
stuff about coop occupy and GPUs it's
really varied but it's nice to have an
in-depth 90 minute talk with some
interaction so you can really take a you
bring your own laptop and you can really
learn something by doing it yourself
everyone who takes things into
production is an actual superhero
definitely well I think it's really
important because usually they the
scientists are mostly focusing on giving
the performance of your model but
actually we really need to realize that
there are certain T's for these
predictions that we make so you have all
these sort of technical interpretability
methods like chef that's what kind of
what I use an example and it's all very
cool and sort of nerdy but what I think
was interesting in our story then we use
those and tested it with real doctors to
see if it actually works if it actually
makes stuff interpretable and we learned
a lot of things that didn't work and
some things that it worked it's an
online learning system so like a machine
learning thing where you're going to
learn one by one and we feel that this
is something that there's a gap in the
ecosystem there's not many people that
do this
[Music]
but do not be afraid to reach out and
talk to someone see what they're doing
in their everyday job maybe what you're
doing is similar to what they do maybe
they have a couple more years of
experience and you can learn from them
and that's the whole idea of this
conference we want to come together
learn from one another and have a good
time
[Music]